over a decade of Marvel movie magic 21
films in the MCU dozens of Easter eggs
and hundreds of minutes of action and
emotion it has all led up to this moment
the release of Avengers endgame ahead of
in game's theatrical debut reviews for
the superhero ensemble started hitting
the Internet
critics near and far race to let their
thoughts about in-game be heard and
you'll want to lend them your ear here's
what the critics on Rotten Tomatoes are
saying about Avengers endgame don't
worry you're entering a spoiler free
zone there's a lot riding on Avengers in
game to be a worthy successor to
Avengers infinity war and a capstone to
three phases of the MCU so far
thankfully endgame seems to have EE
succeeded critics say it pays off
everything within itself and much that
preceded it risks of past movies bets
the heroes make here the lengthy runtime
the stakes and storylines the plot we
won't spoil everything
Mashable's angie Han wrote the bet pays
off
the story feels more organic this time
the emotions more earned and the
interpersonal dynamics richer and more
lived-in din of geek called the film a
totally triumphant pay off while susana
pollo a polygon said there's nothing in
game sets up that it doesn't pay off
said David Simms of the Atlantic the
film earns its length not by
overstuffing the frame with opulent
action but by slowing things down and
basking in the charisma of its ensemble
Thanos is demand for a dramatic ending
and infinity war pays off here in all
the right ways russ fisher at birth
movies death agreed rather than closing
things down in game opens everything up
this is a genre film with layers of
overlapping big ideas character
conflicts that could be flat-out
ridiculous if handled with less skill
and deep in jokes featuring dozens of
costume characters ultimately in-game is
an entire movie of payoffs it plays off
and completes thoughts begun in age of
Ultron and Civil War and even in comics
if you thought Avengers infinity war was
heartbreaking you apparently have a big
storm coming with Avengers in game
critics are advising fans to pack some
hankies and wear waterproof mascara when
they head out to see the film as it's
packed with tear-jerking emotions of all
sorts hey it even reportedly made
Captain America himself Chris Evans cry
six times
insiders Kirsten Hakuna wants
moviegoers to hit the theatres prepared
bust out the tissues Marvel fans
Avengers in game is going to make you
laugh cheer aloud tear up multiple times
and cry by the film's in there were
audible sniffles throughout insiders
10:00 a.m. press screening Tuesday
morning in game is an emotional punch
straight to the gut you're going to be
too emotionally distraught by the film's
ending to really nitpick at anything in
endgame viewers won't weep exclusively
out of sadness though as rosy Fletcher
and Richard Jordan at den of geek wrote
in their joint review at times in game
as heartbreaking expect to cry but there
are certain scenes that border on the
euphoric certain character moments
surprises and reveals that hit so hard
in the heart and the head that it feels
like you're MCU drunk even Richard
Roeper of the Chicago sun-times couldn't
help but be moved by in game it's a
serious contender for the crown and it's
the undisputed champion when it comes to
emotional punch Avengers endgame is as
emotionally affecting as any Marvel
movie has ever been okay so we know the
movie will probably make you cry but
that doesn't mean the movie is a sob
fest from start to finish
critics have indicated that in-game
features plenty of the emcee use
trademark humor which helps steady the
sentimentality jake Kleinman of inverse
explained thor delivers some of the best
jokes an end game sometimes without
saying a word the Washington Post's
Michael O'Sullivan concurred saying as
high as the stakes are in endgame it is
also a very funny movie it seems one of
the movie's most prominent strong points
is its ability to mix emotion with
comedy and avoid tipping too far to one
side as the guardians Peter Bradshaw
wrote the sheer enjoyment and fun that
it delivers the pure exotic spectacle
are irresistible as is its insouciant
way of combining the serious and the
comic without the comedy the drama would
not be palatable yet without the earnest
almost childlike belief in the
seriousness of what is at stake the
funny stuff would not work either
National Review critic Kyle Smith might
have said it best when he wrote a sombre
aura gives Avengers in-game its gravitas
but the movie is also funny rousing and
above all endearing where there are
lovers there are haters or in this case
people who didn't fall completely head
over heels for the feature bold and
beautiful as it evidently is the film
still isn't immune from critique though
the vast majority of reviewers Bay
basically gave endgame full marks a few
critics took a more well critical
approach to the film Forbes senior
contributor Scott Mendelssohn wrote that
endgame is flawed and feels as if it
copied certain beats of infinity war
though it's still entertaining and ties
up the threads of the MCU nicely it
doesn't make a ton of internal sense
suffers from narrative claustrophobia
and the action leaves a little to be
desired Avengers in game is a merely OK
MCU movie but there is grace in its
failings Donald Clark of the Irish Times
argued that in-game spends too long
wallowing in its own pomposity and is
short on fun Christian long at glide
magazine called it a subversive
compelling and thoroughly unsatisfying
film that chooses to rely on vacuous
fanservice instead of taking the time to
put any real heart into its storytelling
once certified Rotten review came from
Globe and Mail's Barrie Hertz who wrote
the entire endeavor loses any sense of
emotional stakes or general meaning
beyond the deliverance of crass
fanservice and incomprehensible visuals
it seems that for every fault one could
find in Avengers in game 10 times the
amount of merits exist sure a handful of
critics weren't roused by the superhero
ensemble and that's a-ok but far more
were moved enough to exalt it as a true
achievement and stamp it with perfect or
near-perfect scores
why according to Germaine Lussier with
io9 the film is everything you've ever
dreamed the Marvel movie could be and
then some in versus Jake Kleinman wrote
that the film definitely delivers on its
promise of big action and bigger heart
with its third act feeling quote unlike
anything we've ever seen before in the
history of the MCU as the movie finally
ended I felt different almost as if I
was glowing like brie Larson's Captain
Marvel the result of eleven years of
world building has arrived and it feels
like nothing will be the same again in
his review of endgame Nick Johnston at
vanya land said the film is everything a
fan could want and feels like an actual
ending to the story writing it doesn't
feel like a teaser for another movie
later on down the line its content with
satisfying you the devoted in the here
and now the Salt Lake Tribune Sean P
means offered a similar analysis writing
Avengers in game delivers everything
Marvel fans will enjoy and not much that
they expect Earth's Mightiest Heroes
fulfill their promise in
installment that takes a decade of
superhero storytelling and ties it
together into an astounding emotional
conclusion check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
Avengers in game art coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]